[Applaudissements]
bientôt pâques thomas fait
ouais mais qu'est ce qu'un humoriste
cynique sinon une sorte de christ qui
prend sur lui tous les péchés du monde
pour les tournées en joie
bien sûr non sérieusement leur est
beaucoup plus grave les sondages les
sondages des us à 40 points dans la
tronche de hollande valls 58 olemps 18
comme quoi pour plaire au pays le mieux
encore c'est d'arriver dernier aux
primaires du ps
[Applaudissements]
ces
jeux madame moi je ne comprends pas
c'est un différentiel énorme et 40
points 43 tu as l'impression que valls a
gagné à l'eurovision et que hollande est
soupçonné de détournement de mineure
enfin y'a un truc pas exagérer bataillon
ça continue comme ça valse il va devoir
se séparer de hollande
la cohabitation sa vie de faire des gars
je vois déjà la france m'a chirac à
propos de sarko qui a dit je décide il
exécute hollande pourra bientôt dire à
propos de valls j'hésite il m'exécute
alors c'est pas le plus important le
plus important en ce moment c'est
l'algérie et parce que maintenant ça va
quoi ça va moi j'en ai assez de voir
bouteflika stigmatiser manqué à longueur
de journée le mec il est pudique il est
pudique
savent pas ce qu'est ce qui parce qu'il
va pas qu'à rester le cul des moutons ça
y est c'est un légume c'est vrai j'ai
habité 12 en algérie c'est un beau pays
et j'en ai j'en ai assez de ces préjugés
parce que pourrait pas être un peu fier
de la médecine française fin de vie
depuis qu'il s'est fait soigner en
france le mec qui n'a même plus besoin
de se montrer il est là on a quand même
les meilleurs thanatopracteur du monde
que j'ai à dire
chez moi j'ai acheté un renard empaillé
c'est mon côté nature et découvertes et
regarder la télé tranquille le renard et
la vue bouteflika il était jaloux
utilise
dans l'algérie cc c'est un vrai pays
c'est un pays jeune 70% de la population
qui a moins de 30 ans et moi je pense
que l'algérie elle a besoin d'un mec
d'expérience on est d'accord et
bouteflika il a quand même connu la
grand-mère de giscard
qui connaît vraiment belaziz qui sait
encore que lors de la commune de paris
ils étaient staff est sur les barricades
bouteflika c'est un destin un témoin à
l'âge de 10 ans lorsque le dédale j'ai
donné les clés du pays à la france
abdelaziz s'enfuit à paris où très vite
il ouvre une gargote place des vosges
intime de zola [ __ ] de victor hugo il
est introduit dans le showbiz de
l'époque où abdelaziz se fait rapidement
appelée hip hop
là il fait la teuf avec roda il se bat
avec puccini fait un gosse à sarah
bernhardt puis s'enfuit avec arthur
rimbaud à ibiza pour mettre au point les
rimes riches et la cocotte-minute
sarments et et là c'est rien c'est
encore rien la guerre éclate ça va le
révéler définitivement qui se souvient
encore que c'est lui qui a soufflé
l'idée des taxis de la marne à joffre
moi je revois la scène tu sais dans taxi
joffre qui dit aller au front et l'autre
côté où vous avez un itinéraire préféré
ou quoi j'offre nom et bouteilles que
réponse je crois si mu on passe par la
marde
[ __ ] de génie tactique
vingt ans plus tard c'est toujours le
même qui sautera d'un ulm je rappelle
qu'il ya 150 ans à l'époque
sautera sur les plages de normandie
libère calais le havre toulouse
nouakchott le rayon death metal du
virgin megastore avant de sauter sur un
vélib sont sévères stalingrad prendre
les allemands en revers [ __ ] ça c'est
un mec quoi jamais s'arrête la guerre
est finie mais boutef ils s'emmerdent
l'heure il agi
après avoir traversé trois fois
l'atlantique à la nage en marche arrière
et en apnée
est descendu la face nord de l'everest
en bobsleigh il enchaîne cette fois
égale le tour de france devant louison
bobet raymond poulidor lance armstrong à
qui piquera le maillot jaune et grand
seigneur et lui firent à la djellaba de
son pote d'enfance lawrence d'arabie
[Applaudissements]
et ça parce que doutais bouteille
c'était pas un aventurier stern
intellectuelle monsieur en 1906 au
concours lépine
dans la foulée du dépôt de trois brevets
dont un pour des tas plane le trombone à
coulisse et le fil à couper céleri rave
il invente la fibre optique le modem la
freebox c'est encore trop tôt
de retour de la fosse des mariannes
où il établira le record du monde la
recherche de boîtes noires on apprenait
et slip licra
il a embauché dans une start up
californienne
ils font de google apple et une chaîne
de fast-food spécialisèrent les cupcakes
activités que lui laissons quand même le
temps de pratiquer sa passion ses
arrangements musicaux pour stevie wonder
les clashs et les pet shop boys seul
ombre à sa carrière une apparition assez
décevante dans les aventuriers de
l'arche perdue
néanmoins il se rattrapera plus tard en
inspirant hergé le touchant mais
paisible personnage d'abdallah dans les
cigares du pharaon bien sûr ils sont pin
français majeurs goûter flic ou voyou
[Applaudissements]
alors quand je vois les jeunes cons
accrochés à leur playstation quand ils
ont la chance d'avoir la tête de leur
pays un mec qui a fait sauter sur ses
genoux haroun tazieff
ouais
l'algérie pardon alors pour le reste de
l'actu schumacher 1 phase de réveil
depuis le 30 janvier ça il ya des
progrès c'est pas encore ça c'est pas
encore ça il arrive à dire maman mais
seulement quand on lui montre un brocoli
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle de la semaine claque
alors il paraît que hollande a toujours
la photo de trierweiler sur son bureau
c'est pas une photo sur un tableau de
chasse
beau gosse alors elle est pas belle la
vie et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux